build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building students at MIT
built a 6-foot LED Tetris that's
controlled with dance dance revelution
mats the color kinetic LEDs are in laser
cut acrylic tubes and if you're
interested by the link below to read the
code that they used John guy made this
rocking horse bike inspired by none
other than Charlie the Unicorn
the galloping motion is created by the
asymmetrical mounting of the wheels and
it was on display at Maker Faire Bay
Area 2011 the 2011 Nazareth adult
soapbox derby Chris made this t65 x-wing
fire
he even features an r2d2 spinning on the
back made out of styrofoam and the gel
tone is a partially edible toy piano
created for the jello mold competition
and recently a second one was built out
of fruit salad here's what it sounds
like drawing artist Mike Bell creates
portraits on matchbooks
the idea was to create art on a commonly
discarded item and events the matches
themselves to add dimension to the
portraits for some salt portraits check
out the works at Bashir sultani it takes
him about 40 minutes per portrait one to
two full salt shakers and a piece of
sharp paper he has a ton of portraits on
his YouTube channel including one of a
dude you might recognize Henry the worst
has a collection of pop-culture
fist-bumps from gaming and comics to
movies
[Music]
it's tan she'll make celebrity
caricatures and has a ton of great ones
including Lulu Dexter and my favorite
agent Cooper from Twin Peaks playing
last week this video of a floppy disk
drive playing the Star Wars Imperial
March was posted where the sound comes
from a magnetic head moving based on
specific frequencies this cover of John
Lennon's Imagine was created in one take
with the camera mounted on a vehicle and
various musicians lined up along the way
[Music]
sheering
these guys take the idea one step
further and bring their band to the
highway
finally pit Finnell made a live cover of
the dubstep track scary monsters and
nice sprites
[Music]
we're not done yet submit your own
beauty piece at facebook.com slash
Vsauce gaming and as always thanks for
watching